e come chiusura per questa giornata
impegnativa oggi mi sistemo i capelli
perché
fanno veramente schifo grazie facendo
no no ti denuncio ho denunciato per
molto meno
no no sono lo youtube per senza
contenuti che non ha più idee ed è
triste
allora faccio un video dove i tagli
capelli che è molto triste però fa lady
louise tante mine vivevo professionali
sì
[Musica]
passiamo alla parte successiva
ciao ragazzi sono fabi jail sono venuto
qua da ibs per fermare un po di copia
del mio libro
almeno se volete la mia colpa mia sono
venuto qua dei ds per suonare un po di
copie perchè siccome non potrò fare
prima coppia tutta italia
nel film un po così potete trovarle sui
ds scrittura sessi non number one
siamo arrivati al limite di questa cosa
vorrei questo libro che questa sfida è
finita
ringrazio ringrazio tutti quanti per
essere stati presenti qui come allora
ragazzi siamo dentro il museo della
scienza della tecnologia
sto giocando sia of thieves e poi sono
ho parcheggiato e siamo al motivo della
scienza parcheggiato malissimo tra
l'altro perché incastrata comunque siamo
al museo e adesso vediamo la strategia
grazie papà grazie beh sono con alice
alice lorenzo e no perché c'è gente che
c'è gente che va mangiato patatine c'è
la mano che sta di patatine
[Musica]
io so di patatine
vabbè comunque praticamente stiamo
andando vede che stia mandando istruisci
ci hai parcheggiato come che si chiama
tokyo tolti l'avete trovato nei pac
proprio liberi che hanno né quello che
ti monti con lei in edicola il pezzo in
edicola madonna in quanto è grosso
regalo non vi giuro vi giuro è veramente
grato perché poi magari dal video non si
capisce mai e grosso adesso vediamo se
riusciamo ad entrare nel sottomarino da
fare un po di ripresa dell'interno se vi
faccio vedere come all'interno di un
sottomarino di fare la vede il nostro
scegliamo la questa cosa se non si
capisce chi dice che deve fare la
vedetta perché se no arriva arrivano le
scolaresche e se arrivano alle
scolaresche un casino perché poi il
basso si è dato a fare i self sete
questo momento figurarci anche il
campanello aspetta l'ora
ritrovato davanti da lì si lanciavano i
sicuri
no perché c'è un magnete che vorrei
fargli vedere presto ma come perché la
figurina del napoli e poi qualche
marinaio che la fan del napoli sarà
contento di napoli juve riscopro qui me
ne intendo un sacco ha veramente detto
anche dentro nostro padre si vede
veramente no campagne si vede sul serio
non sto malissimo ma se si tour non
abbiamo no non ci consola è una emozione
incredibile si vede davvero questo se
rischio farvelo vedere non penso però
che vediamo aspetta
oh mio dio fighissimo bellissima trovò
giorno bello questo è carino aspetta la
verità la vedetta
riprendi la vedetta abbia avvistato navi
nemiche ai avvistato navi ok via via via
via appoggiamo la dieta lo sportello 16
b c'è un tesoro come scoprire nel 16 b
cosa c'è dietro un ragno gigante o
sapevano bene che cosa volevano questi
ragazzi sapevano molto bene e niente
oggi e io volevo fare una passeggiata
tranquillo ma non c'è verso è grande e
black mirror una giornata al museo
tranquilli macao che blake mille
telefoni le foto schiava casa poi a me
va bene che sono uno che si sballa ma
che anzi io sono espansivo non sono per
niente timido e ci calza a pennello in
questa situazione ho parcheggiato e fra
e niente la situazione andata migliore è
la situazione è andata a [ __ ] perché
ovviamente andare in un museo è un
casino
siamo entrati nel backstage
quindi chiedo allora come vedetta non
sei buonissima se fossimo stati sotto il
mare con una nave nemica le mie patatina
poverino lorenza l'hanno preso i nemici
cioè abbiamo incrociato un corridoio di
ragazzi sono macello
eccolo è salvo e libera arriverà
una bella ciao bella ciao ciao ciao mi
sembra adesso in montagna su un braccio
un pezzo